بالعوده الى الشان السودانيه افدى مراسل
الجزيره في الخرطوم بسماع يدوي انفجارات
في محيط القصر الجمهوري في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وكانت المدينه شهدت
هدوءا حذرا الليله الماضيه وفجر اليوم بعد
مواجهات امس بين الجيش السوداني وقوه
الدعم السريع وكانت انفجارات شديده قد دوت
امس تزامنا مع تصاعدي اعمده الدخان
الشمالي حي كافوري وحول منطقتي شامبات
والصبابي بالخرطوم بحري وحلت خوجلي
والجانب الشرقي من جزيره توتي بالخرطوم
ياتي ذلك رغم دخول سادس هدنه بين طرفي
الصراع حيز التنفيذ ومدتها ثلاثه ايام
واظهرت صور طائره تابعه لسلاح الجو في
الجيش السوداني من طرازيل وهي تقصف مواقع
للدعم السريع في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم
كما اظهرت صور نشرت على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي امس الاثنين مشاهد جويه لحرائق
في منطقه بحر بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
بعد معارك وقصف متبادل بين قوات الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع